notre état d'esprit à cet instant
c'était qu'après avoir survécu à ce
terrible ouragan on pouvait survivre à
tout le reste
mais on avait tort
on a retrouvé quarante cinq cadavres sur
place
comment ça a pu arriver
je subi énormément de pression pour
mener une enquête sur ce qui s'est passé
durant cinq jours nous avons dû
affronter les pires conditions possibles
on va évacuer tous les patients de
l'hôpital on est des infirmiers c'est
notre travail
n'abandonnez pas ici
on pourra se montrer réaliste quant à la
situation
on ne peut rien faire d'autre pro
notation
sp rendre ça le moins pénible possible
une minute de quoi on parle
ils m'ont demandé d'enquêter sur les
morts ou mémorial medical center anna le
bureau du procureur général concentre
son enquête sur vous
il suggère que la vie de plusieurs
patients a été écourté je me suis assuré
que ces patients ne souffrent pas
certaines personnes craignaient ce qui
se passait hors de l'hôpital mais moi
c'était le contraire
si vous aviez le choix entre soulager
les patients
accordons une mort rapide
les abandonner en les condamnant à une
mort lente
quel choix feriez vous
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai fait qu'aider les gens c'est
tout ce que j'ai fait